filmé dans cette séquence les deux
personnages se retrouvent après quinze
ans de séparation
une rencontre dont on ne sait si elle
est réelle ou imaginaire comme tu es
belle comme ça j'ai même dû cheveux
blancs regarde mais je ne vais pas il y
en a quelques-uns mais ça te va copier
toi aussi tu es bien qu'elle n'a pas
changé du tout va à peine ami lequel
validé il ya eu de me téléphoner il
était un petit signe de vie non c'est
vrai j'avais envie depuis longtemps de
quoi mais dis-moi dix mots qu'est ce que
tu venu faire mais non nous dit rien
je préfère croire que tu es venu pour
moi c'est maintenant qu'il faut j'ai
saisi la première occasion de jeu ne
sais pas pourquoi mais tu es plus
cliquer sur ton souligne le monde s'aide
les souvenirs de notre grand amour moto
mon coin de moi dans le cinéma actuel
le film de dino risi est tout à fait
nouveau d'abord par son ton qui est un
ton qui appartient au cinéma fantastique
et pourtant qui traite un sujet réel
fils s'agit de quelqu'un qui est mort
mais qui survit cependant et il y a à la
fois dans ce film une trame policière
parce que jusqu'au bout on est là sans
savoir si vraiment cette histoire est
vécue ou si elle est né dans
l'imagination du héros de mastroianni en
l'occurrence alors dino risi qui est
présent avec nous sur ce plateau
pourrait m'expliquer pourquoi cette
ambiguïté sur la mort et son mystère il
veut parler du côté policier du côté
mystère mais moi je devrais dire que le
film que je fais en tournoi c'est plutôt
une histoire d'amour moi je vous dit m
l'accent sur sur ce côté du film c'est
une grande histoire d'amour entre normes
qui a beaucoup aimé une femme qui se
retrouve on nous dit qu'elle est morte
et c'est l'un d'eux qui recommence et
l'amour qui va au delà de la mort voilà
c'est le grand amour je pense sur vire à
la mort mais est-ce qu'elle a réellement
existé quand il a rencontré sa double
qu'il rencontre est il un homme malade
ou est ce notre lot à tous nos noms et
la rencontre un réalité oui elle est
bien vivante et le reste de question que
vous me posez ces questions que le
public doit résoudre